hey youtubers is Charlie so Superman
Black Adam meeting up during Christmas
to tease future Justice League stuff not
this current Justice League movie but
the one after that
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video and be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss out on
anything so what's going on
The Rock and Superman in a movie
together like what are they teasing
they've already shot Justice League is
Black Adam gonna be in Justice League
well I would bet that if he's going to
be in a Justice League movie it won't be
the first one and a lot of you are
probably just thinking of the return of
Black Adam that animated movie where
they threw the beat down on each other
bad is always easy magic indeed you are
my physical match but I sense one
critical difference a vulnerability to
magic
another difference here heat vision in
what's probably happening here is that
they're just slowly getting ready to
ramp up for other Justice League Man of
Steel's stuff
so the first Justice League film has
already been shot they're gonna do
reshoots but I don't think they're going
to be adding a whole lot of characters
when they do those reshoots they're just
going to be doing different scenes with
the characters they already have black
Adam is like this whole other big
concept in the DC movie universe that
they haven't even got to yet just the
idea of magic Wonder Woman is kind of
halfway there but she's not really true
magic in the sense that the wizard
Shazam black Adam in the Shazam family
are so I'll explain Black Adam versus
Superman because they're like the last
big time that they fought each other was
during a big villains United arc which
is hilarious because it also has a very
cool twist on the Superman vs flash race
where the reverse flash is forced to
raise bizarro to get him to join the
secret society of super villains so I'll
explain that in a second but the other
like side note smaller reason I think
for Henry Cavill to meet with the rock
is because the rock is just blowing it
up as a PR machine he was one of the
highest earning entertainers of the year
and he's one of the most followed people
on social media like as a cultural icon
right now you know whatever you think of
his movies he is just blowing it up in
one of the things that Henry Cavill in
the past has not been as good at has
been his public persona like his social
presence because while he definitely
looks the part he has his fandom he just
doesn't have that social presence in
that acumen that the rock has so the
rock is probably just going to be giving
him some audience development pointers
while they're developing all these DC
movies so we have all this Justice
League stuff going on right now in the
Shazam black atom movie seems like it's
so far away I think DC is just trying to
find a way to use the asset that is the
rock as much as possible as soon as
possible because when you have like this
bright shining star you don't want them
to ride the bench forever like you want
to find a way to work them in in an
organic way the problem is is that black
Adam has
only bought Superman a couple times in
the comics the last big one like I said
was during this big secret society of
super villains arc and that was back
during November of 2005 so that was a
little over 11 years ago but you can
obviously see the value of having Black
Adam in a Superman movie
it's just that Superman is so weak
against magic you need a villain they
can take him down
so because Superman in this DC movie
universe has never faced somebody that
wields magic or a challenge like Black
Adam it's just a really interesting way
to intro the Shazam family of characters
before they get their own movie down the
line so where would you do something
like that you could totally do it in a
Man of Steel movie but I think it'd be
more valuable in that second Justice
League movie you know maybe small teaser
in the first Justice League movie but
they've already shot most of that and
you don't want them to fall into the
trap of them stuffing too many
characters in the first Justice League
movie is dedicated to the return of
Superman in the teasing of the New Gods
in the forces of apocalypse via
Steppenwolf and like the slow emergence
of Darkseid so we're really talking
about Black Adam in the second Justice
League movie or the next man of Steel
movie which is still undecided on when
that's going to come out they've already
started developing the Man of Steel
sequel but they haven't said anything
about what the story is going to be what
characters they're going to use so
either one of those you know Man of
Steel or second Justice League movie
which has now been pushed for the Batman
movie so originally they were going to
release the second Justice League movie
a year after the first Justice League
movie was going to be like a matrix
situation where you have like one movie
each year but then because of all the
problems in the DC Universe Geoff Johns
being brought in them reworking stuff
they decided that the Batman movie would
be a stronger pick to follow up Justice
League so Batman got the Justice League
slot during 2018
just as League Two got shuffled to 2019
so no worries it's going to be awesome
but it's like so far off the Zack Snyder
is already going off to do some other
small indie movie between Justice League
movies and they actually haven't said
whether or not he's coming back to
direct the second Justice League movie
they just said that he's doing some
other small movie after Justice League
comes out so you guys can let me know
where you want to see Black Adam for the
first time
you want to see him pop up during the
second Justice League film and just cake
Superman's ass and then go on to the
Shazam movie or do you want to see him
pop up during the Man of Steel sequel
and then go on to Shazam I feel like
they're going to try and use the rock as
much as possible so even if they do
introduce him in the Man of Steel sequel
I still think that we're going to see
him first in that second Justice League
film because I think that'll drop before
the Man of Steel sequel so Black Adam
vs. Superman if you haven't read this
story
it's Action Comics number 831 it was
during the big villains United Ark the
name of the story is called black and
blue which you just can imagine what
that implies they just beat the crap out
of each other so here's the pullquote to
start it off
Superman says to black Adam I do not
yield Adam I mostly do painful beat down
how many can I put you down for so
Superman officially throwing the
gauntlet down to Black Adam provoking
him but like I said the issue starts
with Lex Luthor talking to the
reverse-flash
there's like an a story of B's story in
a sea story so the a story is really
like Black Adam vs. Superman the B's
story is reverse-flash trying to recruit
bizarro to join the secret society of
super villains and then the smaller C
story is about Lois Lane trying to find
out what the government is doing with
Superman they have all these shady plans
going on so the episode starts with
Superman confronting dr. psycho who's
being protected by Black Adam noticing
that the supervillains are starting to
become more and more organized so that's
part of Lex Luthor's grander plan to
assemble the secret society of super
villains like I said one of the other
big stories of the issue is the
reverse-flash trying to recruit bizarro
to join so that they have somebody that
can neutralize Superman but here we have
black Adam who is also just as effective
at doing that so the setup here is
pretty epic
Superman's remembering how there used to
be blight on his family's cornfield and
when that happened there was only one
thing you could do rip it out by the
root so he's getting ready to rip black
Adam and dr. psycho out by the root so
you have like this epic standoff and
then like the small tiny dr. psycho here
sort of serving is like the ringside
announcer like ding ding ding all right
here we go left corner right corner the
epic beatdown of the century so
Superman blames black Adam for a lot of
the damage that's been happening
recently in his backyard in Metropolis
black Adams like I had nothing to do
with that and then he notices that he's
protecting dr. psycho another notable
supervillain so he just gets madder and
madder as dr. psycho tries to provoke
them into a fight Superman lays hands on
them let's go and then that's just the
end of it Black Adam is not taking any
[ __ ] and they just go at it he notices
that black Adam hits a lot harder than
Captain Marvel they're still calling him
captain marvel at this time in the
comics there was a big legal problem
with Marvel so now DC has to call their
Billy Batson Captain Marvel Shazam
that's why you don't hear him being
called Captain Marvel anymore but
effectively black Adam has all the same
powers as Billy Batson which is that
morally he's very ambiguous so sometimes
he uses his powers for personal gain
sometimes he uses them to help people
it's really hard to see which side of
the fence he's going to come down on so
he's worked with the JSA in the past but
he's also fought them to a standstill
there's probably one of the reasons why
the rock wanted to play him he's a
badass character and he sort of fits the
profile in the rock also gets to be
something of a villain and a hero at the
same time the fight itself actually
gives Superman the opportunity to not
hold back just knowing that Black Adam
can take the punishment like he's always
so careful with the way he treats other
human beings just because he would snap
them like toothpicks if he weren't
careful he does not have to pull his
punches with Black Adam so as they're
beating the crap out of each other in
Metropolis Jimmy Olsen catches some of
it with his camera just like oh my god
this is amazing
dr. psycho mine controls Lana Lang to
attack Black Adam so Superman freaks out
Black Adam backhand sir Superman is able
to save her but you know you see the red
eyes here just completely loses it so
Black Adam just sees things escalating
and he himself has to stop it by turning
his back on Superman knowing that
Superman would never punch somebody in
the back just like someone with great
honor would never shoot somebody in the
back so with a punch that would have
split the moon in half the fight ends in
black Adam says that dr. psycho will be
brought to justice
says they call a truce and then Superman
lets Black Adam know that he knows that
they're forming a secret society of
super villains we have information that
you're forming an evil team of
metahumans which is actually something
that's happening in the movies too and
I'm not talking about Suicide Squad
so the movies always change a lot of
stuff about the comics but you can see
what's happening in the DC movies right
now we have the threat of Steppenwolf in
the forces of Apocalypse coming to fight
the Justice League whose slowly
assembling in this first Justice League
movie but then what's going to happen
around the rest of the world when they
see this big team-up like Captain
America Civil War the world sees the
collateral damage and they want to hold
the Avengers accountable like you need
to be under government oversight the
governments of the world need to have a
say in what you do when you're in each
of their countries so I wouldn't be
surprised if in future Justice League
movies there's also something like that
forming in the background Amanda Waller
even said during Suicide Squad more
nefarious governments are collecting
their own metahumans just like she's
collecting her Suicide Squad villains so
her whole reason for forming the team is
so that they have somebody to fight
these other metahumans and get them
under lock and key before other people
can get ahold of them and use them for
something really terrible so one of
those are the people right now is lex
luthor who's currently in prison he's
fascinated by metahumans he has a bunch
of files on them so it makes sense that
he would go around and try to recruit
his own team they could counter the
Justice League if he wanted to so one of
the highest people on his list
knowing that Superman is back during the
Justice League movie would be Black Adam
like Lex Luthor would need to find
somebody that could fight him because
until they find some more Kryptonite
like the only kryptonite that we know
about is Batman's kryptonite spear so
unless they find some other sitting
around Lex Luthor has no way to fight
Superman so let me know in the comments
how do you think that they would invoke
Black Adam in the movie would Black Adam
himself go after Superman if they were
to act somewhere around Khandaq like if
the Justice League came in without black
Adams permission I could see how he get
pissed you're in my backyard this is my
country I rule here how dare you Black
Adam is a care
isn't really interested in the affairs
of the world so it'd be pretty hard to
recruit him before Superman did
something in his country that he didn't
like so my vote for Black Adam vs.
Superman would be Superman in the
Justice League just crossing into his
territory and doing something that
causes some collateral damage that
pissing off Black Adam and then him
going after them because of that
so when related news a lot of Superman
stuff happening today there is a super
girl lives trailer which is based on the
Kevin Smith Superman lives movie that
did not get made it was a complete [ __ ]
show but it is the most fascinating
crazy story ever so I'm going to do a
trailer video and explain that Superman
lives movie but it was the Nicolas Cage
Superman movie
so that'll post later today still on
Justice League trailer watch so
everybody just keep your eyes peeled for
anything that might drop but I think the
fall back if they don't drop it in the
next week or so is they'll just wait for
the Super Bowl that first week in
February because there's just a couple
more weeks away and just like this huge
big event where the entire world's eyes
are just focused on this one place for a
brief period of time so that would be
the place to drop something if you want
as many people as possible to watch it
within a couple hours and I'll say
congratulations to this week's flash
ring giveaway winner David from South
Park please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there is a new round
that started now I'll announce another
winner later today when I post that
Supergirl trailer video with the
Superman lives story well you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
the next big flash episode trailer and
you can click here for my Justice League
in the flash saved Christmas video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight